ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
annoncé avoir porté plainte contre
audrey pulvar qui l'accusent de diffamer
la police samedi sur france info la tête
de liste des socialistes aux élections
régionales en ile-de-france avait jugé
glaçante la manifestation des policiers
mercredi devant l'assemblée nationale et
y est allé fort regardez et dites moi ce
que vous en pensez c'est ce qui ne
fallait pas louper
loupé qu'avez vous pensé de ce
rassemblement
il s'est déroulé exactement comme je
l'imaginais et c'est bien pour ça que je
ne souhaitais pas y participer je
l'avais annoncé dès le matin les
manifestations à l'appel de policiers en
colère
soutenu par l'extrême droite à laquelle
participe un ministre de l'intérieur qui
marche sur l'assemblée nationale pour
faire pression sur les députés sur la
représentation nationale en train
d'examiner un texte de loi concernant la
justice c'est une image qui pour moi
était assez glaçante
alors qu'est ce qu'on pense d'audrey
pulvar gilles verdez mais je ne
comprends pas pourquoi monsieur darmanin
porte plainte
pour moi c'est honteux c'est la liberté
d'expression d'audrey pulvar en pleine
campagne électorale c'est absolument pas
diffamatoires a le droit de dire ce
qu'elle veut
voilà bah oui vraiment se compliquer
avec portes à elles deux elles dit quand
même que que la police marche sur les
institutions de la république
elle dit que la police est dans un
système de racisme généralisée d'armes a
lancé le patron de la police
donc être en campagne pour les
régionales en ile-de-france et régional
salue autorise pas tout c'est pas parce
qu'elle est en campagne qui peut marcher
comme ça sur dharmanand pour la police
mais la police il ya des gens très bien
dans la police il faut pas marcher plein
mais il ya aussi des gens pas bien
apprécié la critique
tu ne peux pas laisser envoyer le
message de dire tout le monde a droit de
dire tout et n'importe quoi mais lui
l'un des patrons de la police
il a estimé qu'il fallait porter plainte
peut être pour eux un pour calmer tout
le monde
et ben si la droite porté plainte pour
diffamation il porte plein dans les
cascades l'impôt devrait pouvoir la part
dans tous les sens mais c'est dommage
nicolas pernikoff je voudrais d où le le
départ de la manifestation c'est suite à
la mort d'éric masson bien sinon il est
le représentant de la police oui ils se
battent contre l'insécurité c'est pour
ça qu'il ya eu cette manifestation donc
ces propos sont totalement déplacée elle
est là pour être bien pour une élection
audrey pulvar donc c'est bon les lacets
ceinture et va se retrouver
jean contrairement elle est l'oubli elle
oublie les raisons de la banalisation
des sancerre et les civils et elles ont
fait des raisons c'est de l'eau pour les
moissons mais j'ai pas lu à moi elle est
là pour la fracture elle est là pour
david accords coûte que coûte voilà un
débat politique et idéologique elle est
exaspérante dans tous ces propos mais je
pense même année ne devrait pas porter
plainte
pour les autres d'autant plus qu'à la
manifestation y avait à l'hidalgo pour
laquelle elle travaille pour l'olivier
fardeau qu'est de son bord politique
dont elle espère qu'ils apprennent donc
elle devrait carrément pas démissionné
voilà ce serait beaucoup mais
actuellement justement porté plainte
pardon oui mais justement moi je suis
entièrement d'accord avec toi nicolas le
point de départ de la manifestation à
l'oublier c'est l'hommage à éric masson
dans cette manifestation toutes les
tendances étaient représentés or
systématiquement les médias ont insisté
sur le fait que c'était une
manifestation soutenue par l'extrême
d'armé alors dans tout le monde était là
comme je trouve ça extrêmement odieux et
audrey pulvar le sait très bien
quasi parfaitement faux cul dans ce rôle
là les gens se soignent dans quelques
pas de là je suis non mais c'était alors
son discours allez plutôt pas d'accord
il est d'accord avec le film allait pas
d'accord avec la forme c'est ça le truc
à l'ap a critiqué en soit la police à la
critique est l'événement qui s'est
déroulé avec moi je regrette qu'ils la
mettent en valeur c'est la récupération
politique de sa porte d'entrée poule var
c'est rien du tout bonjour foot droite
est en campagne ou à la campagne mais
utiliser sa part des femmes politiques
et minable c'est nul est logique
moi je suis à titre personnel je suis
pas d'accord avec ce que dit audrey
pulvar mais ça ne tombe pas sous le coup
de la loi donc luc louis les 1000 lui le
ministre de l'intérieur il n'a pas à
s'opposer à une liberté de parole une
fois d'accord parce que dans ces cas là
il faut qu'il aille jusqu'au bout
puisque s'ils l'attaquent audrey pulvar
x trac et mélenchon mais est-ce que
c'est mélenchon caselli dit tu vas
propos de sa mélenchon il dit les flics
sont des bons à rien et
il dit il dit que cette marche pareil il
dit exactement la même chose donc
pourquoi pas quelle instance étaient 55%
oui 54% non 46% voyez oui 54%
je peux comprendre ce que veulent dire
les gens merci d'un an avec audrey il y
avait des précédents
[Rires]